I began to realize that there was sort
of this insatiable demand for for
computing performance and that that
demand would wouldn't be satisfied any
time in the in the near term unless we
could figure out a way to put tens or
hundreds or even thousands of
microprocessors together to work on one
of these these very big single problems
so I eventually went to my management
and said you know I know you have me
looking at at other companies but I have
this idea of starting a business that's
sort of based on this notion of using
lots of micro processors somehow I
managed to convince them this was a good
idea something worth investing in and
for literally the next ten years we we
were on on this chase to to build the
world's fastest computer which we
succeeded in doing bye-bye 1996
an interesting way to look at it is just
to think about the various cylinders in
your in the engine in your automobile I
mean we you know we have four cylinder
engines and six-cylinder engines and
eight-cylinder engines I have an Abba
car that has a ten cylinder engine and
they're even some with 12 or more
cylinders so instead of having one giant
one giant cylinder that's trying to
generate all the power to move the car
use use a number of smaller ones and and
the aggregate power is what is what
moves the car at you know at freeway
speeds and we're in a sense doing the
same thing by using lots of micro
processors to generate generate high
performance we're we're taking their
individual power and and harnessing it
in such a way that we can bring all of
their energy to bear on on one single
very challenging computational problem
I built my first computer or calculator
i guess more accurately when i was 12
and I had to I had to learn about binary
arithmetic and you know how computers
did did arithmetic and and that really
you know took me into you know to
learning new things about math and
certainly you know electrical
engineering because it was all part of
creating that that calculator the fact
that I could actually build an
electronic device that could add
subtract and multiply couldn't do divide
I wasn't quite up for divide but but do
three of the of the four basic
calculator functions and that that it
would do it repeatedly endlessly and
always get the right answer that I think
that kind of determinism is what really
what really captured me
I can't remember exactly how old I was
probably 10 or 11 but a neighbor boy and
I had this idea that we should have a
private telephone link between our
houses and so we we set out to to build
the link and we got the we got the sort
of the endpoints figured out but then
came time to run the cable from my house
to his house which was we were you know
several houses apart and and we never
managed to get that that cable to work
the funny part is years later one of the
neighbors asked me to remove the cable
and because they were doing some you
know some landscaping and so I walked
along the fence pulling pulling the
cable out and I came to this point where
that cable and the other cable that was
coming from from my friends house were
simply nodded together there was no
electrical connection between the two so
that was that was an ill-fated adventure
but my first attempt at inventing
something